well there's so many parts to answering
that question I i think the the big idea
if there is a the big think or or the
accidental happenstance was when i was
trying to solve a story problem if a
person could live forever a person was
immortal how would they change over time
I was curious about whether one lifetime
was enough for somebody there are some
people you know those arrested
development type men who can't really
outlive their outgrow their adolescence
and I thought well maybe one lifetime
isn't enough maybe you need more so I
was just thinking through if a person
could live long enough how would they
change and that seemed like a cumbersome
experiment because of having to deal
with changing history so I was trying to
solve the problem how you can have a
person be immortal without having
history change from underneath them so
that the movie would not the story of
the movie would not have to deal with
the French Revolution and and with the
future and things like that and then to
solve that I remembered an idea i had
had about a year or two before that
about a guy repeating the same day and i
realized that having a person receipt
repeat the same day turns an eternity
into a circle and and that's when all
the dramatic possibilities came and the
comedic possibilities and although the
the resonances with repetition so that
was the idea like that I was actually
getting ready to read one of Anne Rice's
novels about vampires and I was sort of
thinking about why I thought that was
interesting and the most interesting
thing to me was that it was a different
class of people there just like people
except some of the rules were different
and the most interesting one being that
they were immortal and that's what got
me thinking about immortality there
that's all of it
yeah well I thought of the funny things
first the very first thing I thought of
was the date seen being able to use your
superior knowledge to pick up women and
as soon as I thought of that I knew I
had a movie that just seemed to me so
extraordinarily interesting and fun and
funny so I guess I was approaching it in
a comedic way but it wasn't as onra
comedy I was thinking of it more as just
a whimsical entertainment
this is one of those things that just
kind of fell together when I got the
idea of a man repeating the same day
over and over again it was like january
thirtieth or 31st and so the first thing
i thought of is I've got to think of
which day he repeats which day is it and
so I just opened up the calendar and the
first holiday day I came to was two days
later groundhog day and I was thinking
about that saying well this is perfect
it's a completely unexploited holiday
that can play it on TV every year like
the Charlie Brown special but other
things started to make sense immediately
to like I didn't I wanted him to be a
character who went somewhere was an
unfamiliar territory if he was on his
own to his home turf with his family and
friends it would be a completely
different story and by making a
groundhog day I thought okay so maybe
he's a weatherman and he comes from
Pittsburgh and he drove to Punxsutawney
for the ceremony and so and the the
groundhogs name is Phil so I'll name him
a fill and a bunch of things just
started falling together in that way